this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
and today he's going to be breaking down
the guns of escape from tarkov
just to see how accurate the game's
arsenal is portrayed
spoiler alert he's pretty impressed so
we've got the the
macaron the sound effects are probably
the best i've heard
let us know if there are any other games
guns or mechanics you want jonathan
to break down in the comments section
down below make sure to subscribe for
more videos like this
and if you want to support jonathan's
work and the royal armouries museum
check out the links in the description
of this video
alright here's jonathan's take on escape
from tarkov
of course wow um this is the first time
seeing of
taco i've heard a lot of people talk
about it seeing a lot written about it
that it has a lot of realism in its
depiction of firearm and just from that
short
clip right away i can see what they're
talking about
so we've got the the makarov or makarov
very much a cold war
pistol very much a sidearm it's not not
really a combat weapon although
people with the training can obviously
use it that way and it's really nicely
modelled the sound effects are
probably the best i've heard just from
that short clip
but that that sounds like a gun being
fired in a building perhaps
um i don't know how much it changes as
you move in and out of spaces perhaps
we'll see and the way it's handled is
really cool the
brass check the press check that he does
to make sure that it's chambered around
a bit of a modern thing but um it is
done and it is in there and you get to
see the cartridge in the
in the gun the only thing that threw me
off initially was the
the wacky drum magazine which i am not
familiar with as being a real thing
and i can't imagine why it would be a
real thing as far as i know there isn't
a drum mag for a macaron perhaps someone
can
prove me wrong but i really like what
i'm seeing so far
pausing okay i'm even more impressed now
the one thing that i thought was a bit
wacky with the drum magazine the logic
or the lack of logic there would be that
it makes it very heavy
and uncontrollable the physics of all
that would make would mean that the
muzzle
would wobble about as you're trying to
shoot it and that's exactly what we see
happen
which which i'm really impressed by
that's a really nice mixture of
unreality in using a drum magazine with
a pistol which is uncommon
and absolute attention to detail in
making the weapon
change how it's being fired i've not
really seen that done in that way before
uh the other thing i i really like is
the depiction of muzzle flashes
depending on where you are in the
environment and
whether the gases that that have been
produced on firing happen to reignite or
not which is the main cause of muzzle
flash
this this is a realistic depiction so a
lot of shots you see fired are nothing
but smoke
and then on on some shots in some light
conditions
you get more of a classic muzzle flash
so
there's an awful lot of attention to
detail here
[Music]
awesome so the gun we're looking at here
is of course the the p90
really nicely done again i'm often
obsessing about rates of fire when i'm
when i'm looking at stuff like this and
that looks to be spot-on
sounds great looks great we've got i
think the the base model of p90 as
i have behind me somewhere with the ring
sights
optic on it from the early 90s and this
has got
side rails fitted to it allowing the
accessories that we see including
the green visible laser
um so this this being a thoroughly
russian game it's not at all surprising
that a lot of what we see
is our firearms of of russian or
old soviet origin and the the as val
makes a lot of sense in this game it's
all quiet all the time effectively and
to aid that it's firing
a very interesting cartridge it's
subsonic
so it won't make that crack as it leaves
the muzzle
inevitably everything's a trade-off so
just like as with the american
equivalent 300
whisper or 300 blackouts you get reduced
penetration and the beauty of this game
is that you can swap out different
ammunition types
which will allow you to tweak that
compromise between
effectively stopping power and quietness
but given that you are skulking around
in
a sort of post-industrial landscape
trying not to die
a very quiet weapon that is automatic
and relatively speaking has good
penetration is is
going to be sought after and i suspect
it will be in the game as well
[Laughter]
so we've just seen our unfortunate uh
player there
run out of ammunition that quiet click
must be the loudest click in the world
in real life when that when that happens
what happens amusingly
is the two actually interact uh in
in sort of virtual space usually with
the game your the
the emitter of your bullets would just
click through all your bullets would be
stopped by the by the model in front of
you but it
wouldn't be a realistic interaction but
interestingly what we see there is that
the shotgun that the guy's trying to
kill him with gets pushed against his
body
and can't effectively finish him off at
least he might hit him but
he can't can't be finished up and he's
able to then pull out an entrenching
until
beat the guys so it's something new that
i've not seen in a video game before
in terms of how people and weapons
interact in the physical space
both the firearms and the guns are
firing where they're pointed
they don't magically snap to the aiming
point and put a bullet out
in the same direction they always would
they fire where they're pointed which is
which shows how well
everything is modeled
pausing that's a really nice ak
it's it's the ak-101 part of the 100
series kalashnikov very very well
depicted i think
good rate of fire good model good
textures
all the right features are on there well
modeled in semi-automatic mode
it's climbing too much in automatic
slightly frustrated to see that
because that muzzle break that's on the
end of this series of rifles
is tremendously effective now if you if
you're loosely holding it
yeah it probably will still climb
vertically but a trained person
or even the likes of me can hold a
weapon like that on target
on automatic and it will pretty much
just sit there the downside is that the
guys to the left and right of you get
deafened
if they're not wearing um hearing
protection because the blast is going
out sideways
and to the rear to pull the gun forward
against recoil
pausing well there's your problem
it was going so well until we saw the
stock being folded up now
firstly i should say brilliant to see
the stock actually getting folded up
so to have it modeled at all is really
impressive uh whereas with this magazine
on it's not really a problem
we take that off and we fit the
rpk drum magazine that we've just seen
fitted in the game
you've seen the problem already the
folding stop just clips
through the drum magazine so i'm sure
this this being a game that's not
still in progress i'm sure they're going
to address that because it's it's a
fairly it sticks out a bit like a sore
thumb when you see it happen
okay you're gonna pause there i keep
talking about gameplay rather than guns
but uh i'm just
very impressed with with with all it
really but um like most first person
shooters it doesn't really matter what
you shoot someone with
unless unless it's modelling like a 50
bmg or something and there's some
graphic effect on the target and the
ragdoll 50 feet away or something like
that
normally the sort of the injury or
animation death animation
is fairly consistent and it's sometimes
a bit underwhelming
this game seems to it knows what weapon
you're shooting what ammunition is
loaded in it
and what effect that's having on the
enemy something like this sv98
powerful cartridge 762x54 again the
russian
long-range cartridge effectively now um
and that has a lot of punch so that's
why we see what we see when the
guy goes tumbling out the tower and
people just drop like a stone when
they're shot in the head with this thing
pausing there the toz bolt action
shotgun
that we see here is definitively a a
civilian weapon
bolt action shotguns are not
particularly common they have the
the downside of being slow to to operate
there's usually a better way to do it be
it pump action
lever action even or a self-loading
design it's it's an interesting one it
makes sense in this context
um and looks appropriately sort of
apocalyptic
so i can see why it's in the game i'm
not sure how popular it is in the game
uh a 20 gauge shotgun is not as good as
a 12
gauge shotgun broadly speaking
pausing we've got another uniquely
russian weapon
in this uniquely russian game the ks23
and it's it's a it's this
unusual 23 millimeter cartridge type
with quite a range of different
ammunition
and we see two different types here
we've got that ear ringing
um flashbang round that's that's very
interesting in terms of gameplay
normally you'd have to throw a grenade
to have that effect
the other cartridge we see used here i
gather is effectively a buckshot type
conventional shotgun round
unusually for a video game it's it's
used at quite some distance i don't know
what real world distance that equated to
that we saw there but the ability to
shoot someone at that distance is
very unusual in a game going going right
back to doom 2 with the super shotgun
shotguns are this bizarre devastating
effect out to about
five meters or something and then just
suddenly the
it's like the neo it's like neo in the
matrix just stops the pellets in mid-air
and they drop to the ground or have have
no real effect
real life's not like that buck shot at
sort of beyond 25
ish meters is perhaps questionable in
terms of will you hit them and will the
pattern cause enough damage to
to drop an enemy soldier especially if
they're wearing armor
nonetheless you can hit a man-sized
target at that distance and
probably at the distance that we saw
there and even if you hit them with
two or three of the pellets they're
probably going to be
seriously reconsidering their options at
that point
pausing um yeah i didn't i didn't
realize they'd modeled nerf guns in
uh tarkov as well as real ones because
uh
for an m4 this is not very effective so
what what's actually happened in that
clip there is
the guy is shrugging off shots and it's
not necessarily reflecting the um
capability of the of the weapon or the
ammunition as in the real world it
it depends where you're hit very much
how much adrenaline is in the system how
motivated you are
perhaps people are on drugs even all of
which affects how
you respond to a gunshot wound on the
face of it seeing this
guy get hit multiple times i'd expect
him to respond
visibly to being hit in some way and he
doesn't so i'm not sure
about that but the fact that he can
carry on fighting until the last shot
hits something critical
is absolutely realistic the the rifle
itself looks to be
well modeled um our player here has
really tricked it out now this is not
uncommon to see
people like the ar15 platform for
the ability to accessorize depending on
their level of training
they will often pile accessories onto
these guns to the point where they
become cumbersome
and a little bit ridiculous and this
being a
realistic game i suspect the handling
characteristics do suffer
when you've got every accessory under
the sun attached to your rifle
uh right the mp5 i'd be disappointed if
there wasn't an mp5 in this game
classic gun one of my favorites there's
a check animation that you see there
where the magazine's taken out and you
can see the round in the top of the mag
very minor detail but it looks like it's
modeled as a single
column or rather a single feed at the
top and actually if you look into a
loaded mp5 magazine
you can see the round next to it because
they sit side by side
partly what makes it a very good
magazine incredibly minor detail
considering that not many years ago
we've got first person shooters where
there are no bullets visible in the
magazine
this is well modeled but i think the
very next level of precision
might be to to more accurately to pick
the rounds in the magazine
i'm gonna pause okay i feel like i'm
being trolled here
because the mp5 has suddenly been
customized to death
as well it's got everything under the
sun on it but an eotech site we've got a
neotech magnifier we've got a laser
light module
some sort of foregrip modular 4n to take
all of that
and i think i saw a drum magazine as
well possibly a different stock
so just illustrating the lengths that
one can go to
but um just because you can doesn't mean
you should
thank you so much for watching um this
has been a breakdown
of the weapons and the ammunition of
escape from tarkov
and i am thoroughly impressed so i hope
to see you again
in a future video if you would like to
we have got a link to
donate to the royal armouries uh it's
difficult times at the moment for
museums it will help us continue to make
videos with our friends at gamespot no
pressure at all but if you feel that you
can would like to
please do donate
[Music]
you